bonsoir nous sommes le 28 janvier
nouvelle semaine pour le 7-8 votre
rendez vous quotidien avec l'information
une heure pour faire le point sur
l'actualité locale et aujourd'hui lundi
nous allons parler pour débuter cette
émission du mariage pour tous avec tout
d'abord ce chiffre le chiffre de la
mobilisation de ce week end ils étaient
125 mille selon la police dans les rues
parisiennes pour soutenir le projet de
loi qui sera examiné à l'assemblée à
partir de demain qui doit permettre
l'union de deux personnes du même sexe
un chiffre qui monte jusqu'à 400 mille
selon les organisateurs nous aurons dans
un instant en ligne avec nous clément
ortega pelletier conseiller régional du
front de gauche il faisait partie du
cortège ce dimanche pour le moment voici
un premier point sur les titres les
sujets qui vont être développées ce soir
dans le 7-8 la manifestation en faveur
du mariage pour tous je vous le disais
entre 125 mille quatre cent mille
personnes dans les rues parisiennes
parmi eux des syndicats étudiants et des
lycéens de saint quentin en yvelines qui
ont pris le départ depuis versailles
vous le voyez tout savoir de la police
technique et scientifique elle 50% des
faits élucidés dans le département le
sont grâce aux technologies de
recherches physico-chimiques lille une
équipe de 68 policiers dédiés à cette
expertise nous en parlerons aussi tout à
l'heure avec un invité sur ce plateau
en sport le challenge d'extraits scream
de trappes traditionnel challenge
interclubs 160 tireurs présents dans les
yvelines également des tireurs des hauts
de seine de seine maritime
au classement final c'est le vésinet le
club de brice guyart double champion
olympique au fleuret qui l'a emporté
devant le club de saint quentin en
yvelines le club de trappes comment
apprendre à se défendre en cas
d'agression un stage de self défense
associé à du kickboxing ça doit être
plutôt efficace était organisée à bois
d'arcy et puis pour les amateurs de
sport donc le 7-8 sport bonsoir anthony
ce sera dans une vingtaine de minutes un
point complet 26 minutes pour faire un
point complet sur l'actu sportive
au programme de cette suite sport
évidemment vendée globe nous serons en
direct avec le skipper versaillais
d'initiative coeur tanguy de lamotte qui
est à l'heure actuelle au large des
côtes brésiliennes nous parlerons aussi
de ce 32e de finale de coupe de france
de football féminin brûlant entre
montigny et le psg qui se transforme en
calvaire
je recevrai harnes heureux reichert
président du club de badminton de magna
oh qu'il vient d'être labellisé pour sa
formation et puis comme d'habitude en
fin d'émission tous les résultats du
week-end l'essentiel du sport à suivre
dans une vingtaine de minutes pour
l'instant le mariage pour tous va nous
intéresser examen du projet de loi à
l'assemblée nationale à partir de demain
et hier dimanche ce sont les partisans
de la réforme qui étaient dans les rues
réunis à paris et nous en parlons ce
soir pour les manifestants c'est un
succès malgré une mobilisation moins
importante que les opposants à la
réforme les partisans du mariage pour
tous estime avoir été entendus parmi eux
des étudiants de l'université de
versailles saint quentin en yvelines
ils se sont réunis dès le dimanche matin
à versailles à la gare tout simplement
avant de rejoindre le cortège parisien
reportages de la rédaction
le débat sur le mariage pour tous
s'ouvre à l'assemblée nationale ce mardi
dimanche entre 125 milles et 408
personnes étaient dans les rues
parisiennes pour clamer leur soutien ce
projet de loi et dans le cortège des
étudiants du syndicat unef et du
syndicat lycéen une aile parmi eux les
illinois partis en fin de matinée de la
gare de versailles chantiers comme
sébastien étudiant au lycée hôtelier de
saint quentin en yvelines
ce n'est pas sa première manifestation
et ce combat s'inscrit dans les valeurs
de son syndicat s'est toujours battu
contre les discriminations que ce soit
les discriminations face au racisme les
discriminations
face au au sexisme et aussi les
discrimations face à l'homophobie
et aujourd'hui on est dans la rue parce
que toute avancée sociale qui permet de
dison banaliser l'homosexualité à la
société c'est un progrès pour nous c'est
pour ça qu'on est là pour défendre ça
c'est important de montrer que le projet
du gouvernement compte qu'il est soutenu
par une grande majorité de la population
les étudiants divinement rejoint le gros
de la troupe sous une bannière commune
unef une aile
il était environ 10000 à défiler parmi
les autres manifestants une mobilisation
qui a convaincu sébastien il s'est dit
satisfait tout en déplorant le manque de
couverture médiatique
quant aux opposants au mariage pour tous
il ne baisse pas les bras
samedi le collectif yvelinois la manif
pour tous appellent à se rassembler à 15
heures devant la préfecture de
sai pour demander le retrait du projet
de mariage d'adoption et de procréation
médicalement assistée
notre fait du jour consacré ce soir au
mariage pour tous examen de la loi à
deux mains et déjà hier une mobilisation
dans les rues parisiennes je salue à
présent le commissaire thomas budo
bonsoir soir merci d'avoir répondu à
notre invitation vous êtes le
responsable de la police technique et
scientifique dans un instant vous nous
présentez vos services ils sont
sollicités ces derniers temps avec une
hausse notamment du cambriolage dans le
département des yvelines pour le moment
le conseiller régional clément ortega
pelletier du front de gauche est en
ligne avec nous bonsoir clément ortega
tout d'abord un mot concernant la
mobilisation de ce week end une
mobilisation un peu plus faible pour ses
partisans de la réforme par rapport aux
opposants on parle d'environ 800 mille
personnes il ya quinze jours on est
plutôt sur une échelle entre 125 milles
et 400000 ce week end pour vous c'est un
succès malgré tout oui c'est un succès
je vais pas rentrer dans la bataille de
chiffres par ce que j'ai
parce que je suis jamais rentré dedans
parce que c'est compliqué il ya eu de
longs articles dans les journaux entre
autres le monde qui revenait sur comment
on comptait dans une manifestation donc
voilà ce que je crois surtout c'est que
oui c'est un succès parce que vu le
temps nous avons eu hier on peut dire
que c'est une c'est un succès quatre
cent mille personnes et puis je crois
surtout que le résultat des sondages qui
sont publiés ce matin nous confortent
dans le choix d'aller vers ce progrès ce
progrès social quel mariage pour tous
alors on parle aujourd'hui de 63 % des
français qui sont favorables
donc c'est à dire une augmentation de 3
points en 15 jours je crois que on est
sur une mi-temps train de convaincre
très largement très au delà de ce que
nous pouvions convaincre gafi moi des
gens de l'utilité de l'égalité des
droits
le débat qui ne fait que commencer
véritablement ce sera à l'assemblée à
partir de demain pour les responsables
politiques en mars vraisemblablement
plutôt pour le pour le sénat vous
attendez quoi des discussions qui vont
s'engager auprès des députés ensuite des
sénateurs je crois que les députés ont
et les sénateurs ont bien
le débat de fond qui a dans cette
société il me semble évident que
l'ensemble des deux chambres vont voter
la loi parce que c'est parce que c'est
du bon sens parce que c'est de la
logique parce que c'est une loi
républicaine et profondément
républicaines de l'égalité des droits
je ne me fais pas de soucis sur le
mariage pour tous ce pourquoi
j'interpelle moi aujourd'hui
les essais sur la continuité d'aller
plus loin sur la question véritablement
de un certain nombre de dispositifs
comme l'adoption et la procréation
médicalement assistée justement le front
de gauche qui déposent des amendements
qui va déposer des amendements à
l'assemblée vous souhaitez la
réintroduction de cette pma dans le
texte qui avait été enlevé par le
gouvernement tout à fait sûr quand on
ouvre l'ouverture de deux nouveaux
droits pour des gens il faut l'ouvrir
jusqu'au bout et répondre à la demande
de deux de ses droits
voilà je crois que ya tout un débat non
là où j'ai envie de te dire un peu plus
particulièrement c'est que le débat que
nous avons depuis quelques mois ont
laissé une odeur j'ai envie de dire un
peu amère dans ce que j'ai pu entendre
entre parfois dans vos sur votre sur
votre plateau même où je trouve que on
est plus sur une homophobie latente mais
une homophobie qs d'exar et qui je
trouve aujourd'hui en 2013 me sens
complètement hors de propos
les discussions qui ont qui se
poursuivent qui ont même qu'ils ont été
très longs gains depuis la décision par
françois hollande de mettre justement ce
débat sur la place publique ça faisait
partie de ces propositions
c'est de ce mariage pour tous vous
regrettez que les discussions soient
soit aussi long on est presque un an
après son élection et aujourd'hui encore
les choses n'ont pas véritablement
avancer il aurait fallu peut-être s'y
prendre différemment vous auriez
souhaité avec le front de gauche que le
président intervienne différemment sur
cette cette réforme
vous savez je suis pas dire qu'il faut
absolument réduire les débats qui ne
faut pas de débat je trouve juste que
entre ce débat là et le débat de
aujourd'hui qui traverse véritablement
la situation de notre pays qui est la
question d'une politique d'austérité ou
une politique de relance ce choix là
n'est pas mise en débat et je trouve ça
dommage donc je vais est à dire qu'il
faut réduire le débat sur le mariage
pour tous je pense juste qu'il ya
d'autres débats qu'il faut avoir qu'il
faut approfondir et permettre aux
français de décider et aujourd'hui voilà
je j'ai un peu l'impression qu'on crée
un débat brêlon sur un sujet important
certes et que d'autres débats qui
mériteraient autant de temps et autant
d'hommes neufs d'attention sont pour le
coup un peu escamoté je pense à des
décisions comme je le disais économique
et politique je pense aussi à la
question de la guerre au mali jeudi
prise de position de la france qui
mériterait des départs et en france
pour vous dire asie très brièvement très
brièvement ce qu'on passe beaucoup de
temps sur le mariage pour tous et je
trouve ça bien
je le redis j'ai entendu des propos qui
ont révolté je me dis quand on va
aborder la question du droit de vote
dans l'est pour les étrangers je
m'attends aussi à un débat qui mérite et
qui prouve bien qu'aujourd'hui dans
notre république il faut que nous
allions plus loin dans le changement des
mentalités donc pour un changement de
société en profondeur
en effet du siècle des lumières le pays
des droits de l'homme
il faut qu'on soit si le pays qui dans
le débat philosophique et de l'égalité
des droits que nous soyons à la merci
quel nom merci clément ortega pelletier
conseiller régional ile-de-france pour
le front de gauche d'avoir été en ligne
avec nous voilà ce qu'on pouvait dire ce
soir sur cette mobilisation
de leur côté les opposants à la réforme
qui appelle à se réunir une nouvelle
fois dans les prochains jours et puis
pour en savoir plus sur ce dossier je
vous renvoie ça notre site internet vous
pourrez consulter toutes nos éditions
nos pages spéciales concernant ce
mariage pour tous
page spéciale à retrouver à consulter
librement sur notre site autres sujets
que nous abordons à présent ce soir la
police scientifique et technique des
yvelines qui nous ouvre ses portes alors
que les cambriolages augmentent dans le
département + 6 % en 2012
le pts la pts la police technique et
scientifique met en avant ses dernières
évolutions vous allez le voir